the billionaire goal once you hit that
like what's next what would be next
it's just continuing
alex's boring recipe for success let's
just keep doing what's working um i
would just continue to do that i'm
trying to design it so that every single
party that touches it benefits it's like
an ecosystem of what i'm trying to build
so
everybody who consumes all the content
for free gets hopefully
value foreign access to the time that
they're investing because that is the
real cost it's the time that you're
investing and consuming the content
right and so if you get value for an
excess of that then you will be left
better off and that's going to be 99.9
of people because i'm not selling
anything for the 0.1 percent of
companies that we may end up partnering
with those companies will benefit
because we'll be able to directly invest
in them and we'll help them grow the
team that i have within acquisition.com
i'm recruiting the absolute best in the
world so we're talking about people who
have uncapped earning potential so they
can make five hundred thousand a million
two million dollars a year five million
dollars a year um within that structure
so the people who work for me will be
able to make you know tremendous amounts
of income and create their own
independent wealth